welcome back everyone so today i'm going to start
a mini lecture series on complex analysis which is
essentially the study of numbers and functions
of complex variables z where z has a real part
and an imaginary part we write this usually
as x plus iy x is real uh y is also real but i
y is imaginary and in my kind of college math
class this would usually take up about two
weeks the series i'm about to to give you
right now uh i think i'm hoping to do this
in about 12 or 13 little mini lectures
i'm really hoping it ends up being 13.
the inauspicious and occasional number of
lunar months that fit into a solar year
okay so complex functions and complex variables
come up all the time in differential equations
ordinary differential equations odes
like when we deal with pendulum swinging
or if we have a a mass on a spring that is
oscillating pretty much anything in physics
that oscillates that moves back and forth is
going to involve some kind of complex function
usually we think of this motion as periodic so
it's going to be described by sines and cosines
and what we're going to see very very quickly
is that sines and cosines are actually the
imaginary and real parts of a complex
exponential function so very cool stuff
um good now when um when i start i like
to to kind of define what i mean by i
this imaginary number most of you know this from
you know from high school or grade school you've
seen this before we say that uh you know i equals
or is defined as the square root of negative one
so we know what the square root of nine is it's
it's you know three but it could also be minus
3 because minus 3 times minus 3 is positive 9.
and very quickly uh in school you realize that
these negative numbers don't have a real valued
square root there's no real number that when
squared will give you a negative number and so
you have to introduce this imaginary this this i
this other variable i that is defined as the
number that when squared equals negative one
this has bothered humans for centuries um all
the way back in the 1500s actually i think all
the way back to alexandria it was recognized
that you needed other numbers uh to take these
square roots but especially in the 15 16 and 1700s
lots of mathematicians really wrestled with what
this meant they didn't like this number descartes
called this imaginary in kind of a derogatory way
and it wasn't until euler and gauss you know
a bit later that this really started to become
an established part of mathematics and if you
think about it you know even negative numbers
for a long time were not really seen as real i
could of course owe someone you know five apples
which is kind of like negative five apples but you
know the idea of multiplying two negative numbers
and getting a positive number is still kind of
unintuitive for for kids you need to get a lot
of intuition and build up a lot of experience
of how numbers work and how subtraction works
before you can make that leap and this is kind of
the same way but i want to point out that this is
very much not an imaginary number in my mind these
are extremely concrete quantities again that are
everywhere in our solution to ordinary and partial
differential equations so i'm going to walk you
through bit by bit piece by piece how to think of
complex variables how to think of complex numbers
and functions of these complex variables and
we're going to use these over and over again
in differential equations you know to
solve the wave equation the heat equation
spring mass system things like that now in
the uh bronze age when when i went to school
this whole series on complex analysis would have
been an entire you know 10-week class there is a
huge amount of depth that you can study complex
variables in my class that i teach to my students
at university of washington i've condensed
this down to one week of essential material
and then one week of kind of extra advanced
material that i think most students should
know it's almost like you take you know art and
history classes uh so that you have a well-rounded
education kind of a liberal arts education i
almost think of complex analysis that second week
as like a liberal science education it's
something that people should know even if
we don't use it as much as we did 50 years ago
okay good so i'm going to keep going through this
so we're talking about these complex numbers
that have a real and an imaginary part and we
have defined this imaginary number i as the
number that when squared equals negative one
so it is the solution the solution to the
polynomial equation x squared equals negative 1.
and again for a long time people realize
that there are polynomials you can write down
that don't have real valued solutions okay this
bothered people for hundreds of years there's
actually a great veritasium video on the history
of the imaginary number i'll put a link in the
in the description below but it was recognized
at some point down the line i'm guessing
probably gauss formalized this that you need
these imaginary numbers to to write down the
solution of a generic polynomial so if you have
any polynomial i can write down its solution
the roots of that polynomial will generically
need complex valued numbers to express those
roots for example this is a polynomial where x has
to equal i or minus i to satisfy this polynomial
okay and so in some sense that means that these
imaginary numbers are necessary so if we want all
of the solutions of these polynomials uh then
we need these imaginary these complex numbers
to represent these solutions and it wasn't
until quite some time that people also proved
that these are sufficient i can write down any
polynomial any any real coefficient polynomial and
i can represent all of the solutions in this form
so that means that there i don't need some other
variable plus j z where j is some other quantity
to represent the solutions a real and an imaginary
valued number like this is sufficiently rich
enough to capture the solution of all polynomials
and in fact that's even true if i had complex
coefficients on these polynomials if i had i times
x squared equals negative one that would also have
roots that are uh representable by complex numbers
so that's kind of an interesting and important
mathematical fact that these numbers are are are
necessary to represent the roots of polynomials
but they are also sufficient uh they are
rich in us enough class of numbers uh we would
say that the the solutions of these polynomials
are closed under under the complex numbers okay
good so we know that these uh come up all the time
in ordinary and partial differential equations
uh things like this also write down that these
are important in partial differential equations
things like uh the wave equation so if we have
you know the the motion of a guitar string this
is going to be written in terms of sines and
cosines and oscillating quantities we're going
to need complex functions the heat equation
this comes up all the time in the heat
equation again the fourier decomposition
that we use to solve the heat equation is
naturally written in terms of complex variables
this comes up in fluid dynamics so potential flows
it comes up in quantum so the schrodinger quantum
the schrodinger equation natively has is a complex
valued uh is a partial differential equation
in terms of a complex valued wave function
electromagnetism the electric and magnetic fields
can be thought of as the real and imaginary
components of a complex function so really these
are not imaginary at all they come up all the time
in the physical world now part of the reason this
is so confusing and it has been it still is and
it has been for hundreds of years is because
even though when we write down the mathematical
solution of ordinary and partial differential
equations we get complex valued functions
all the time everything we have ever measured
in the real world are real valued i can only
have a real valued angle theta this can go from
you know minus pi to pi but it can't be i pi
same thing with the velocity of this mass that
is a real quantity in terms of real meters per
seconds and so that's still kind of one of the
things that's a little bit confusing is trying to
really disentangle how everything we ever measure
in the real world is real but under the hood kind
of in the the mathematical representation of
these things we need complex numbers uh to
write them down and i think a lot of this can be
understood in terms of this complex exponential
function i'm going to come back to this over and
over and over again this function e to the i theta
so euler's formula euler wrote this down and
it's one of the most important formulas in
all of math is e to the i theta can be written
as cosine of theta plus i times sine of theta
and so essentially e to the i theta for a real
valued or imaginary is let's say for a real value
theta this is a complex number that has
a real part given by cosine of theta
and an imaginary part given by sine of theta
and so all of these oscillating quantities here
like this mass on a spring or this oscillating
pendulum i could think about the position of
this pendulum or the position of this mass as
being given by the real part this cosine of theta
and we know that the velocity of the pendulum
the theta dot or the you know y dot of these
quantities are 90 degrees out of phase those are
the sine theta the imaginary part of this function
and so again everything we ever measure is
written in terms of these real numbers x and y
but those are the real and imaginary part
of a complex valued function okay good so
we're going to be covering this again 12
or 13 lectures on this we're going to get
pretty deep into how to do calculus with complex
variables numerical sorry differentiation and
integration we're going to talk about
special functions of complex variables z
but today i really want to get into you know how
do you actually manipulate these quantities how do
you do simple things like addition subtraction
multiplication division how do you write
these imaginary these complex numbers in polar
coordinates um and you know and at the end i'll
give you kind of a road map of where we're going
to go with this short lecture series okay good
uh so i think at this point what i'm going to do
is just go into you know basic basic things like
how do you do addition and subtraction so let's
just get started so addition and subtraction
and i'm going to say um let's say
that we have you know z 1 equals
x 1 plus i y 1 and we're going to say that z 2
equals x 2 plus i y 2. good so addition
subtraction if i have you know z 1 plus or minus
z 2 then that is going to equal x1 plus or
minus x2 plus i times y1 plus or minus y2
so if i add two complex numbers z1 plus z2 the
real parts add and the imaginary parts add and if
i subtract two complex numbers z1 minus z2 then i
subtract the real parts x1 minus x2 and i subtract
the imaginary parts y1 minus y2 very very simple
if i do let's say multiplication multiplication
i'll do multiplication and division so
multiplication this was addition subtraction
multiplication would be z1 times z2 and we're
going to just multiply this out so we have
x1 plus iy1 times x2 plus i y 2 and
we know that that is going to equal
so just like in you know algebra class you
multiply every single pairwise combination and
add them up so you get four terms x1 times x2 plus
x1 times iy2 plus iy1 times x2 plus iy1 times iy2
and we're going to collect all of the
real parts and all the imaginary parts
so i get x1 x2 that's a real number and i y1
times iy2 remember i squared is negative 1
so that's just minus y1 times y2 so
those are the two terms that are real
plus there will be two terms that are imaginary
and that is x1 times iy2 plus y1 times x2 so x2
y1 and those are both imaginary so this is uh
how you do multiplication with complex numbers
i'm going to show you that this is actually
way easier to do using the polar uh coordinate
representation of these numbers but i'll get
to that in a second uh let's say we do division
okay so division would be let's
say i take z1 divided by z2
so that's x1 plus iy1 divided by x2 plus iy2 and
again from your kind of high school or middle
school math class you probably remember that
if you want to get rid of a complex number in
the denominator you multiply on the top and the
bottom by its complex conjugate by x to minus iy
to x2 minus iy2 and when you do that the
term on the bottom becomes a real number
so if you expanded this all out just like here
you would find that this equals on the on the
denominator this equals x squared minus
i squared that's minus minus that's plus
y squared and this is x2 and y2 and on the
top i'm just going to say that this is z1
times z2 complex conjugate and we define complex
conjugate by this over bar i'll write this down
in a minute just so that you know what that
means uh and so this is z1 z2 bar over this
quantity here is kind of the length or the the
the size of this z2 the norm of z2 quantity uh
squared okay so now i'm going to define what
this means just make a little note here note that
z bar equals x minus i y is the complex conjugate
and the length of a complex number z is equal to
kind of its radius which is x squared plus y
squared square root okay good good uh so now
what we've seen essentially is that we can do you
know all of the basic things we want to basically
be able to do algebra with these complex numbers
we can add we can subtract we can multiply divide
you can multiply these by a constant you know
5 times z you just multiply 5x plus 5i [Music]
and we did this in this kind of
cartesian coordinate system where
you have the real and the imaginary
part but it turns out it's actually
way way easier to do multiplication and division
if instead of writing it like this you write these
numbers in a polar coordinate system so i'm just
going to do that really quickly i'm going to say
that this equals instead of x plus iy we're
going to say that this equals some radius
maybe i'll derive this first okay
this is going to be some radius
times an e to the i theta i'll tell
you what this means in a minute but
let's actually just draw this here so
the idea is that any complex number
x plus iy can be written in terms of the
real part of z and the imaginary part of z
and we can put these on coordinate axes we
can have a real axis and an imaginary axis
that are kind of perpendicular to each other
this is called the complex plane and usually
i'll denote this by this kind of script c and any
number z that i want to represent any number z
that has a real part and an imaginary part
essentially the real part uh is its position
in this x-axis and the imaginary part is its
position on this y axis so x in the real direction
y in the i direction let's say this is
kind of the you know i direction here
but of course i can also represent these in
terms of polar coordinates just like you know
and normally i can represent a cartesian vector
x plus x comma y i can also represent this in
terms of a radius and an angle theta so if i
do that here i would say that the radius is r
and the theta the angle is theta so i can
just as well represent this complex number
in terms of a radius and an angle theta and the
way that we write that is r times e to the i
theta and i'll explain why this is true in a
minute so essentially if this is the angle theta
of z then we know that this uh
position here this x is r cosine
theta and this y direction is r sine of
theta and remember from euler's formula
e to the i theta is cosine theta
plus i sine theta so i can write this
r cosine theta plus i times r sine theta as r e to
the i theta this is how we write this in complex
polar form now i'm going to derive this uh in the
next lecture so essentially what we're going to
do is we're going to take the taylor series the
taylor series for uh e to the let's call it e to
the z and then we're going to plug in i theta in
for z and we're going to find that all of the real
parts add up to cosine and all of the imaginary
parts add up to sine so just take my word for
this right now this is called euler's formula
again one of the most important formulas in all
of mathematics euler's euler's formula and this
is we're using this kind of to write down this
complex number in polar form but what i really
wanted to show you is that complex multiplication
is particularly easy when we write it down in
polar form so let's do that let's say that again i
have a few vectors and i'm going to use different
colors for these so let's say i have some vector
let's call this z1 and then i have
another vector that is let's say
z2 and i want to multiply these
and i'm going to say that z1 equals
r1 e to the i theta 1. so this is theta 1
and its length is r1 and z2 is going to be r2
e to the i theta 2. so again the length of this
vector is r2 if that's its radius in this you
know if i had a circle that would be the radius
r2 and this has a angle theta 2. now if i multiply
those two quantities maybe i'll do this in blue
here so i take r 1 e to the i theta 1 times r
2 e to the i theta 2 that is going to by just
multiplication be r1 r2 e to the i theta 1
plus theta 2. and so this is i think what's really
really neat is that in polar coordinates it's
instead of multiplying this all out and collecting
the real and the imaginary parts which gets to be
kind of a pain if i multiply two complex variables
that are already written in polar coordinates then
their radii multiply r1 times r2 like the the new
vector that i'm going to get out of this this is
let's say z1 z2 the radius of this is going
to be r 1 times r2 so those multiply and the
angles the angle of z1 and the angle of
z2 just add so this uh third angle here
is theta 1 plus theta 2. so this is e to the i
theta 1 plus theta 2. and that's just a property
of how exponentials multiply if i multiply two
exponentials then the arguments just add so e
to the i theta 1 times e to the i theta 2 is e to
the i theta 1 plus theta 2. so that's kind of nice
okay so multiplication and you could kind of
verify that this is also true of division this is
if i wanted to divide these quantities this would
be r1 divided by r2 times e to the i theta 1 minus
theta 2 something like that okay so it's way way
easier to multiply or divide when i think about my
complex numbers in this polar coordinate system
and i mean this is also going to be true when we
do physics when we do ordinary differential
equations and partial differential equations
just like i showed you down here it's going to
be very very natural sometimes to think about
instead of writing things in real plus imaginary
part just to think about it in terms of you know
this kind of polar form e to the i theta that's
going to be more useful when we think about the
wave equation when we think about oscillating
variables in physics as well okay good um
Let me see... what else do I want to tell you.
Maybe I'll tell you what's coming next.
So this is just the very basic tip of the iceberg,
where we have talked about why we care about
complex numbers: they come up all the time in
any kind of oscillating solution of ordinary
or partial differential equations. We've talked a
little bit about what these complex numbers are:
complex numbers are the necessary ingredients to
the solution of polynomials... things like, if I
want a square root of -1 I have to introduce this
"i". We've talked a little bit about the "how":
How do we add? How do we multiply? How do we
divide? And specifically that it is easier
a lot of times to do this multiplication
and division when we use the polar form...
this R*e^... I'll just write this outreally explicitly.
This z = R*e^ = R *[ cos(theta)+i*sin(theta) ].
And againR*cos(theta) is the real part "x" and R*sin(theta)
is the imaginary part "y". These are totally
equivalent representations of this complex number.
And what's coming next... the
next piece of all of this is that
we'll be thinking about functions of a complex
variable. So functions like: what if I take you
z^2... if i take this complex number "z" squared,
you can verify that this will equal x^2-y^2+i*2xy:
that is a complex function z^2. And you can
write down lots of interesting functions that
are going to be useful in the solution of
ordinary and partial differential equations.
Polynomials like z^n; you can write down sin(z),
cos(z), e^z ... we've already seen e^...
so all of our favorite functions from real
analysis, from real valued function theory,
like sine and cosine and exponential -- logarithm
is a hugely important one, Log(z) (I give it a
capital "L" to distinguish it from the real
valued log of z) -- all of these can be extended
to be functions of a complex variable, not just
a real variable "x" but a complex variable "z".
So this is just one example here and what we're
going to find is that there is a huge class
of what are called analytic analytic
functions, like z^2 or z^n or e^z,
sines and cosines... these are analytic functions.
And what that means is that the real part and
the imaginary part this function of x and y
... these functions of x and y are solutions
to Laplace's equation. del squared of let's say
the real function phi equals zero and this again
is hugely important: these are the solutions,
the building blocks of electromagnetism,
of the heat equation, of the wave equation,
of all of partial differential equations.
Much of partial differential equations is built on
Laplace's equation and the solutions of Laplace's
equation are the real and the imaginary
part of these analytic complex functions.
So this is all coming up in the next, let's say
12 or 13 lectures.
We're going to talk about how to do calculus, how to define functions of complex
variables, how to do calculus on those functions,
derivatives and integrals, how to understand how
these are solutions of Laplace's equation... we're
going to derive Euler's formula for the Taylor
series e^, and all of that.
So again this is about a two week course. The first week I would
say is essential to understanding how complex
variables work. The second week is interesting
but pretty advanced material so I highly recommend
the first part but if you're interested stick
around for the whole thing. All right thank you!